when we set out to film this
series we knew that we'd face some
challenges along the
way but nothing
compares to what the wildlife is up
against animal Journeys formed over
thousands of years are in real
Danger
[Music]
physical
barriers
disorientation habitat
loss climate
change making it harder than ever to get
from A to
B some animals are already being
infected before we've even had a chance
to learn more about
[Music]
them East Africa's great Griff
Valley is home to three4 of the global
population of lesser
flamingos
these pink carpets can number over a
million
Birds constantly on the
move they can be tough to track
down the flamingos they're quite
mysterious
creatures
red they come right across the rift
valley looking for the right Lake they
just they do what they want
really only by enlisting expert help did
we have any hope of getting
close scientist Timothy Mami has studied
flamingos for the last 17 years in the
last ticket Flamingo have gone away from
the normal Pink Carpet
legs and nobody up to this moment
understands where they are finding and
filming these unpredictable Birds is
going to be harder than ever this is and
inspir while the crew sets out in search
of the biggest
flocks the science team is a bit more
[Music]
Hands-On wow we've got a lot of
flamingos
the safety of flamingo comes priority
number one we are heading now to process
them at our ringing
station Timothy's new project is using
Rings or bands to find out where the
flamingos are going what is a tried and
tested method used for more than 100
years 1 7 5 how it do fitted in these
days
we can all get involved in bird
science even people at home can help us
to Monitor and conserve Flamingo by
reporting these two plastic Rings the
white one is Kenya and this is Lake
boria once these rings have been
photographed by tourist be it on
Facebook be it on Twitter or any other
media we can easily tell where they were
ringed
across the lake is
luck the crew gets word that larger
numbers are starting to
gather oh there's a bigger group way big
group on the
right lots of lots coming in just
now this is yeah this is pretty cool
yeah and I'm right in amongst them
all sping go all all over the
[Music]
place but Timothy worries that A Flock
this size could soon become a thing of
the
past human activities are coming up at a
very rapid
rate I can tell the changes are not
sustainable
[Music]
it is going to be very sad for our
grandchildren not to find
Flamingo this is the sadest
moment projects like this are the key to
better understanding and
protection how I wish I could have
wings I could have already join
[Music]
them